wer hat bitte in etting dabei und macht
sich die mühe und gibt es ein viertel
liegt das hier so drauf möglichen für
und freiwillig lustig wert gilt dann
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
leute es ist was hartes passiert ich
habe euch auf twitter gebete nicht so
richtig betritt sollte mir erst mal so
videomaterial schicken das nicht so
richtig richtig triggert und ihr habt
gut hinbekommen aber eine sache stach
besonders raus und die chance heute an
ich weiß nicht ob ich lachen oder weinen
sollen leute ein teil von mir meint ein
anderer treffen hier lacht einfach es
ist richtig kraft aber auch irgendwie
wissen eingebracht und chancen das mal
und zwar dreht sich alles um den lieben
mert matan herten video hochgeladen
experiment 1000 grad schlüssel an meinem
auto erst mal was soll ich scheiße 1000
grad ist doch eigentlich tot bau machen
noch videos wir diesen trend fest soll
aber es ist nicht so wie ihr denkmal wie
reagiert man angemessen was ist wirklich
so ein auge von gelacht geweint aber
schon rein wenn wir zum training und was
gerade hier geht einfach mal gar nicht
irgendeine verflixt abwahl hat mir hier
in kraft darauf hatte ein wenig mehr
papier ball ab dann gegen training aber
gucken was passiert
[Musik]
dort kann man einer freundin hab also
wir haben ja auch bald 1000 worden wenn
ihr es alle übergeht und online kanal
abonniert wird auf einem kanal abonniert
ok ich hab' 100.000 manche sie am
wirklichen kind meinte die beiden hier
haben wirklich ein kind oder
übernächsten fall dem titel des halses
garantiert nicht das was der titel steht
solch trotzdem abonnieren wird trotz
abonnieren leute ja kommen wisst ihr was
gelassen aber das braucht anno 2070
haben wir jetzt einen richtigen
vorsitzenden okay geht erst mal auf dein
auto ein ich glaube das auf was mert
matan fährt ich will mir nicht
tausendprozentig sicher ist ein weißer
cla 45 amg stimmt dass also es ist schon
die sportversion von mtl
das heißt das ganze ding ist schon ein
bisschen teurer 280 kilowatt das theater
stark 180 x 136 glaube ich kilowatt im
ps 380 ps
dem jungen der macht richtig partner des
fir und server laufen am bus
ausprobieren und zwar ruft ihr hier ruft
er daher macht genfer training auch das
wirklich spannende papiere nach den
geringen geht man erst mal hinten und
jetzt mit spanien 38 die händler okay
wenn sie jetzt zum training aber als
richtig ist gerade hier
geht einfach mal gar nicht zeigt euch
dort ganz gruppen aber auch irgendein
verrückter typ hat mich in krakau
haha ich denke erst mal alles klar
es hat schon richtig liebe leute da das
ist richtig übel denn dieses auto kostet
mindestens 56.000 euro wenn man das
kauft und da wahrscheinlich niemand von
amg mit serienausstattung kaufte macht
schon mal kein pakt vielleicht so 65 bis
70.000 euro aber der clou ist leute ich
persönlich würde jetzt vielleicht erst
mal denken dass er den vielleicht nicht
gekauft und geliebt hat und bei wie
singles oder zahlt man nur relativ
geringe miete über ein paar jahre muss
das ausland zurück geben aber das auto
muss in einem tadellosen zustand sei
damals zurück das heißt wenn das auto
hier nicht sein eigentum ist dann muss
er wenn ein kratzer drin ist dass die
sündhaft teuer bei mercedes selbst in
der werkstatt machen lassen weil er viel
tiefer kratzer eltern ist so teuer
sondern auch noch so auf komplett
schlüssel an sein auto
das ist der grund warum ich bei dem
video auch mit einem auge lachte wie
witzig kann man fremder leute eigentum
beschädigen es ist selbstverständlich
illegal leute und ich heiße es auch
nicht gut wenn das an meinem auto
passieren würde würde ich aus rate nicht
heulen ich würde aus dem fenster
springen hoch laufen noch mal springen
alleinige türen ein tiefer kratzer damit
kostet das mit ein bisschen pech mehrere
tausend euro garantiert und mehrere
tausend euro dafür bezahlen wrestler
jemanden am schluss an eurem auto war
das ist richtig ärgerlich aber wenn man
schon das loch ist kann man glaube ich
kein lustiges 8000 gras schlüssel
experiment an seinem auto
er sieht was ich nicht glaube ich fühle
mit dir und ich fühle mit ihr ich für
den schmerz wenn nach dem training raus
kommt ein eigenes auto ist beschädigt
was für teuer bezahlt hat und noch
weiter bezahlen muss damit den cup
daraus machen muss aber wie witzig ist
dass der titel suchen sondern ein
arschloch essen sitzen soll
wieso muss man so was erzählt mir dass
allein von experiment 1000 grad schritte
haben wir mit schnupfen muss oder ich
wirklich nicht gut heißen ich lach jetzt
vergabe so ein bisschen im video wie
gesagt ich will das nicht gut heißt
nicht verurteile das sind einfach
mehrere tausend euro ihren dafür
bezahlen muss dass da jemand einfach
eine blöde idee hatte und genau das ist
der grund warum ich mein auto niemals
oder vorerst nicht zeigen werde bei
hunderttausenden von leuten die einen
kanal abonniert haben die euch kennen
gibt garantiert ein paar arschlöcher die
da richtig bock haben euch einen
reinzuwürgen und wenn die wissen wie
euer auto aussieht vielleicht neuer
kennzeichen die pläne von stadt und die
sich in der nähe dann ballert ihr euch
in fetten katzen dort fenster her ich
kann auch verstehen dass man sagt
bolliger mein auto ist nun ein
ich würde mich mein auto zeigen was ist
stolz darauf dass man das hat aber ich
hab schiss davor ich würd man auch
richtig zeigen luca zum beispiel hat
sein auto auf mich gezeigt und das ist
glaube ich ziemlich markt
und ich glaube ich ganz ehrlich ich
würde noch mehr auf lager alle anleihen
würde seine videos passieren würde ich
die kamera so zusammen schreiben dafür
ist noch eher das gefühl sagen das ist
so ein scheiß
einfach einfach hier guckt euch das neue
kumpel
wobei was theoretisch auch sein könnte
man kann jetzt überhaupt nicht erkennen
ob der kater irgendwie tief ist also
wenn ihr jetzt richtig raffiniert ist
wenn er jetzt richtig raffiniert ist und
sich die nacht hat okay wie kant
interessantes video machen hat er
einfach vielleicht ein abbau sparding
genommen und das selbst und sein auto
gemacht allein von der kamera
perspektive her kann man das glaube ich
nicht unterscheiden allein von dem was
wir von der kamera aus wie bis jetzt
hätte doch einfach ein wasserlöslicher
erding sein können wir nach wieder ab
und hat ein gutes video gehabt mich
herum irgendeinem sowas macht beschluss
für das geht einfach komplett gar nicht
das wird echt leute was hat man von
sowas erzählt mir das mal warum macht
man so was ich meine ihr könnt ihr gerne
irgendwo etwas zu tun was hat das auto
angefahren weil es pakete ungeschickt
ausgedrückt von ihm aber ein sicher der
rebellen so was machen wollte er macht
lieber experiment 1000 grad
schlüsselwörter mehr zahlen als gegen
sein auto
es ist wirklich für leute wenn das auto
geleast ist und das wird sich vom gefühl
her vielleicht erst mal sagen dann muss
er das wirklich für mehrere tausend euro
in der fachwerkstadt machen was er muss
es machen lassen wenn das auto sein
eigentum ist wird er wahrscheinlich
trotzdem nicht mehr zum fetten kraft
durch die gegend fahren wenn er kraft
für echt ist und muss dann zumindest mal
für zumindest mal einige hundert euro
und bei der fachwerkstadt ab sondern bei
einem smart repair an machen das geht
echt richtig ins geld da muss man so
tief in die eigene tasche greifen dafür
dass jemand mit dem man nichts zu tun
hat als perfekt ist hat der auto gebaut
das geht euch damit man beschwert euch
was echt schade
man kann nichts machen außer sich
darüber aufregen dass luft leider echt
traurig aber wahr zu machen aber eher
ruhiger als ich finde er ist eigentlich
fasten bis hin zu ruhig dafür dass
gerade irgend ein wildfremder typ
vielleicht mehrere tausend euro schaden
an dem auto von red hat die erste zahlen
hatte ich wieder richtig aufregen aber
erste dimitrow etwas nicht so tun kann
als ohnehin
wir sehen uns gleich zu hause leute das
aber alle entschuldige im trend diese
1000 graz scheiße und dann kommt einfach
sein scheint auch noch prächtiger wer
hat bitte in etting dabei und macht sich
die mühe und gibt so vettel liegt dass
hier gebrauchen
das ist eine rechnung als er ist möglich
nur unfall wenig lustig aber er hat
wahrlich schon gelacht experiment pausen
grafs anderen auf mit smiley auch noch
vor mir leid dass nicht du bist aber man
muss im leben auch mal bisschen schadet
ja nicht irgendwie ich gönne jedem
seinen teil
es ist einfach wesentlich angenehmer
jemandem was sie können anstatt ihn
dafür zu beneiden
dass so eine emotion der wirklich
auffrisst war damit fühlt man sich gut
man fühlt sich nicht gut immer hier ein
paar leidet und deswegen hätte das ist
tatsächlich gehen lieber zur lösung aber
mit können meint jetzt nicht experiment
1000 grad schlüssel an jemanden auto
können egal was und allgemein dieses
nein und heben ich kann mir noch nichts
davon kaufen ich habe einfach nichts
damit anfangen
deshalb würde ich mich freuen wenn ihr
ein bisschen mehr annehmen können noch
sagen muss ist das gewinnen nicht
gewinnspiel gibt sich bei mir innerlich
alles zusammen wenn ich das sehe ich
wirklich 1000 euro ausgefasst gleichen
gehört wohl jeden schade der
fachwerkstadt machen das nur mehrere
tausend euro schaden wahrscheinlich
allerdings wir dürfen nicht vergessen
dass auch der typ der den gameplan
geweckt hat
vielleicht hat er auch experiment 1000
grad abschlüsse an meinem auto geweckt
einerseits man hat mich wirklich gesehen
nach der kasse liegen tief ist und
andererseits wahrheit wirklich sehr
gelassen in dem video ich kann nur noch
mal sagen wenn jemand mein auto so
kicken würde würde ich mir erst mal
denken menschen existenz nämlich
abstoßen und dann würde ich halt auch
richtig ausrasten dann würde den duden
der schimpfwörter von vorne bis hinten
einmal durch beten aber mit anlauf wenn
das wirklich echt war
hut ab in diesem sinne leute ich wollte
heute eigentlich ein road to get back
here machen aber das fand ich dann hier
noch ein bisschen spannender wenn jetzt
finde loswerden wollt du mit der
augenbraue dann schreibt man müsste
augenbrauen die kommentare und leicht da
bist du nicht mal haut rein macht gut
experiment 1000 grad finger wirklich
aufnahme stopp knopf